what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be interviewing the people of london
how they feel about this sign abortion
is a cop out we are in shortage london
so hopefully we can have some good
discussions with people that disagree i
hate this i hate doing this every time
but i love it i love it
but i hate it
[Music]
let's talk to the people of london see
how they feel about this sign
i have a feeling they're not going to be
too fond but we're going to we're going
to see how it goes
oh my god okay so i was waiting to do
these interviews when this guy
approached me and he seemed really nice
and he's actually cute but i just get
nervous but props to you for coming up
to me i know that's hard what
oh my number
um
wait what you want to be interviewed no
i'm okay thank you
he was actually cute i just got
embarrassed i don't know hi guys public
interviews got an opinion hi guys public
interviews public interviews
public interviews
got an opinion
[Music]
what's going on over there you want to
be interviewed
i want to be interviewed
got an opinion
what's your opinion what's your opinion
you're the one holding the sign
my opinion's on the side you're open
you're on the side yeah
agree or disagree i agree you agree you
think abortion is uh
why yeah why because because women use
it as a cop-out for the poor decisions
that they made the poor decisions they
make what's the poor decisions well they
shouldn't have been sleeping with
someone that's not a good father no
that's not necessarily about the father
what's the father got to do with it if
it's yours if it's a woman's decision
well because you need someone to raise
the kid with right so i'm saying it's a
cop-out for making a poor decision
well i think he's ready to be a father
we're not using an iud not using a
condom not using the 10 forms of birth
control that we have to choose from
so you're being irresponsible and you're
using abortion as a cop a woman that
doesn't contraception doesn't really
work with her it makes her it makes her
i don't know makes her bleed inside or
for example the directory plans or
whatever where you think it's a cop-out
because she had sex and unfortunately
got pregnant
what about condom i mean the guy's like
eyes choice no well i get to pick who i
sleep with and i and i can and i can so
if i was gonna sleep with someone i
could require them to wear a condom
that's my choice and if he chooses not
to and then you end up getting pregnant
you think having an abortion from that
point is a cop out so so i really try to
stay away from exceptions rather than
the rule right and and so if i don't
consent if i don't
like this you can't stay away from
exceptions so less than one percent of
abortions are in the case under the case
of grapes so forty less than one percent
and forty percent of women that get
abortions have had two or more abortions
so that's that's to me indicating it's
just poor decision making i don't think
it's poor decision maker and i feel like
it's women that are in a point of time
where they're not ready to to be a
mother uh they are in a relationship
that might not be perfect for them to
have children i don't think it's a
cop-out i think it's a decision that
women should be allowed to make for
themselves i never understand guys that
support abortion why would you want your
girl to kill your kid
that's your kid i don't get it but you
know i guess you know to each his own so
so what i'm saying is that the data
indicates that it is a cop-out because
again it's not making up everything i'm
gonna lie
so so i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying
that they're making a poor decision of
who to sleep with i don't know you don't
think women should be selective with who
they sleep with
i mean i mean yes and no we are kind of
like are you in the street whoa
21st century you have the freedom to you
have the freedom to be so we have the
freedom to do abstinence too anyways
back to the point that you made um
towards um the date of suggest i can't
lie when it comes to data it's
completely just the topic football when
you look at football they are if you
analyze football football of data you
will get the wrong information when it
comes to players if you analyze life
based solely off data you're gonna get
the wrong you're not gonna understand
the human life like how people behave
choices within life decisions timing all
of that counts into it so what do you
think we should draw conclusions based
on if we're not using data draw our
conclusions it's hard to draw
conclusions just freely they are yeah
cool it is nice to draw it is nice to
have an opinion using data however
drawing conclusions just based off they
i don't agree so i think it's hard to
have discussions with people that don't
draw any conclusions based on data
because then it's just how we feel life
is about how you feel though no no it's
the policy is based off of data now life
is about how you feel it's about you
make you make decisions on based on how
you feel now do you think that we should
make policy based on how people feel um
policies policies based on how people
feel yeah going on this logic no no i
can't i know so it has to be awesome
yeah like back tracking all my
statements so it has to be based on data
correct
give me a second you were ready for this
argument i wasn't it's okay i'm not i'm
not trying to i don't edit this out so
they'll see it should we make policies
based on data i think i think if we
basically only make policies based on
they are we're we're really treading on
a thin line based on on what data
suggests in my opinion okay what's the
thin line i feel like if we're basing if
we're just um like i'm gonna have to
scramble in my head now and think for
example
i can't get i can't think of an example
this is a bad argument i've set myself
into because i'm not actually ready for
it no because
my my whole point is like a lot of times
we bring up exceptions and say oh
there's all these far-off reasons that
women get abortions right but typically
in my experience the woman just isn't
being responsible we have all these
different forms of birth control that we
can use like we can if you get a you
call it the coil here you have a 99 plus
chance of getting pregnant there's no
hormones in that or of not getting
pregnant so it seems like it's just a
fail-safe and a cop-out for poor
decision no it's not i don't say it's a
cop-out because you might not be in a
position that you're ready to have to be
a mother there's not like you have the
freedom to live the life that you want
and there are obviously choices that
people can then make afterwards if they
do get pregnant to obviously eliminate
that factor i don't think it's it's not
do you think if you're not ready to be a
mother maybe you should take steps to
have precautions before you have sex
yeah of course i understand punching
what i'm saying it seems like women
aren't doing that because 40 of women
have had two or more abortions that get
abortions 60
that get them in the future so you don't
actually know what person so sorry
refresh me on the statement that you
made originally because i had to go off
from it from the abortion is a cop-out
that's the original no no no from the
little statement that you just made now
say for example a woman makes not
necessarily a mistake but she gets end
up getting pregnant and she's not in a
position that she wants to be a mother
do you feel like she doesn't have the
right to make a decision to be your
mother or not i would say no when you
get pregnant it's a unique dna sequence
that's different from the mother and the
father if we're going to believe the
science 95 of scientists say that life
begins at conception when it's still a
cell and it hasn't actually grown into
anything you think it's the sperm and
the egg meat remember it has a unique
dna code that's different from the
mother and the father it's not just the
cell
so that you that dna code has what the
kids eye color is going to be their hair
color their personality traits and and
that's completely different from the
mothers and the fathers and if we're
going to use the bot the argument that i
hear a lot my body my choice would you
say that they can a day before they give
birth have a have an abortion a day
before because it's in my body accuracy
then you see i think it's an america are
you american yes it's the plan b the one
off the bill would you say that you are
against that completely i actually don't
know enough about plan b to have an
opinion you're saying it from no i i
don't know so like so when the egg is
then fertilized you would then obviously
have an issue with plan b as well
because if that's the case again i'm not
going to make a statement that i don't i
don't i base my i base my opinions on
facts so so i don't i don't know enough
about plan b to have an opinion on it
well i'm not very well equipped enough
with stats or data to have this argument
with you you're very ready still clearly
standing in shortage for an argument
you've won this i'm gonna shake it okay
well thank you i really i really
appreciate i really appreciate talking
to people that disagree so i thank you
for having me enough i'm not ready for
this okay i don't i don't expect people
to be so it's like i you hope so but i
don't think it's a cop-out i feel like
if you have the if we have the um the
abilities the abilities to have an
abortion the freedom you have the
freedom of choice to choose so yeah
that's my opinion towards it it's like
if you have if you have something on
sale and it's not illegal and it's legal
to do so
then by all means use the video
i'm just curious so at what point should
women be able to get abortions up to i
think life begins at birth no so you
would you would support an abortion if i
got an abortion the week before the kid
was born well that's never gonna that
doesn't happen right it does happen
something's gonna happen abortion before
a week before the child was born then
what they're putting okay okay let's
let's let's do two months two months
before that doesn't happen either most
abortions are way before that so i'm
gonna give you a stat okay so in the uk
in the uk abortions are legal up to 24
weeks
the earliest pregnancy to survive is 21
weeks okay so do you not see a problem
with that when the kid could survive
without the money
what's the percentage that happens
the percentage
i i'm not sure off the top of my head
doesn't because again we're talking
about the legality so i'm asking you
should that be and then what happens in
reality so there's
there's the legal and then the reality
of the life i don't see i don't imagine
or see any woman having an abortion at
21 weeks even if it's legal and free i
could look it up i don't want to
misquote it i want to say it's around 20
percent i'm 20 i mean your base your
arguments are facts so you can't bring
that in there unless you're that's what
i'm saying i'm not sure but you don't
have any data i don't have anything i'm
not good that's what i'm saying you
can't argue that women aren't doing it
if you don't if you don't have any data
to back that up but i'm saying i'm 100
sure it's legal and free up to 24 weeks
so so i'm saying should it be should it
be legal but i'm asking you a question
should it be legal at 21. so at 21 weeks
that's the earliest pregnancy that's
survived should it be legal at 24. under
my argument that life begins at birth
yeah 100
okay well
at least you're consistent
if you choose at like um 21 weeks where
it's still legal to have an abortion
then by all means do so they up it to
seven months would that be cool but they
wouldn't do that though you could you
could tell me your country or where it's
ever happened that seven months then
then we hope we would have a
conversation if i if i found you one
would you change your i mean run right
now in a country where you can get an
abortion at seven months then we can
have an argument in the u.s they have
some laws that you can some laws is that
factual exactly no it's not an opinion
it's i i'm positive yeah yeah because
there was a really big good in the uk oh
frank gordon you just you just moved the
goal post again you said if you could if
you could find me something i'm in new
uk marketing for uk factory so then when
i ask you should i add 24 weeks oh this
argument why am i still here 24 weeks
that's the question i keep asking you do
you keep moving the goalpost no it's the
same argument 21 if it's legal at 24
weeks 24 weeks off my top of my head
still six months then yeah but if it's
legal by law then yeah why not okay and
even though a kid can survive at 21. i
mean if the law makes it legal at 24
weeks then by all means okay well thank
you my argument that life begins at
birth in my opinion
yeah okay okay thank you for stopping
you're welcome i like to talk to people
that disagree with me oh yeah so so it's
just a civil conversation
no no i'm not i'm really not i believe
it's a cop-out for poor decisions and
the reason being is no no so so there
are exceptions to every rule but less
than one percent of abortions are for in
the case of grape we say grape on
youtube so i'm not talking about the one
percent of cases i'm talking about the
majority the reason i think this is
because 40 of women that get an abortion
have had two or more abortions so to me
it's saying you're not being responsible
at this point and they're not tracking
the 60 to see how many get abortions in
the future
to me it's you didn't make a good
decision when it first happens or
something like that when there's a woman
who's got single kids and she's he's
going to make her a wealth gap that's
the thing in america so that's it so
with the people
well they're rich aren't they they're
just going to get it done illegally are
they not that's a really not the poor
people which i mean so that's a really
big misconception okay so only eight
percent of women below the poverty line
get abortions one out of three women
that make forty seven thousand dollars
per year actually are getting an
abortion on top of that in the u.s
planned parenthood which is the number
one provider of abortions it's a racist
organization started by a eugenicist
so her her she referred to she referred
to um black people as
weeds think for it to be illegal is to
complete it's complete regression into
us in like in society so um tell me why
because my body my choice do you know
what i mean let me do what i need to do
like men or whatever why should they
decide you know what i mean like why is
that law why is that even a thing this
is a common argument i hear which is the
my body my choice so i'm i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm so so it's you can you can talk
in a second too come on stay there
if you want to be interviewed next you
can sorry i forgot what you said last
night
that it's a regression in society do you
not think my body my choice everything
all of that so my body my choice right
do you believe in abortion up to birth
so if i'm if i'm eight months pregnant i
believe obviously but people you do you
believe life starts at conception is
that what you believe yeah when do you
believe that i think when it's what what
the law is when it's like
up to six months is that that's what you
believe so here's the thing
an abortion is legal in the uk at 24
weeks and the earliest child to survive
a pregnancy is 21 weeks so you're
aborting children that hypothetically
could survive on their own outside the
world do you think that child that was
going to be born like the life that is
going to live do you think it's going to
live a good life and then isn't that
isn't that actually being cruel to this
child that would be born my question is
do you believe that poor children are
less valuable they're not less valuable
they're just not going to have a good
value of life so why should that why
should they why should i put a child on
this earth that's going to not not have
a good quality
when i could give it a good quality of
life when i'm prepared in the future
quality of life so one i have two things
one the majority of abortions are with
women that make over forty seven
thousand dollars per year so it's not an
income thing only only eight percent of
women anything do they i don't i don't
when you're firing back at these facts i
don't they don't mean anything you're
not a person like you do you and 47
grand a year like do you earn that
would you have a baby right now could
you could you do that because to me i
don't think you should be having sex if
you can't afford a child and if you are
if you are then why why can't you get an
iud
so or or or
why can't you get an iud birth control
birth birth control in the uk is free
doesn't always work does it
but this is a common argument i hear
which is we talk about exceptions rather
than the rule if you get you call it the
coil here i i think can i can i find it
can i can i can i can i can i finish my
sentence so so the coil here is 99
effective you're actually really good at
debating yeah so i'll say that you're so
good at debating
here's the thing i'm not i'm not you're
here i'm not i'm not trying to clickbait
you i'm not sure i don't edit it out i
know you guys are just walking into this
i don't expect you to have the all facts
i just i just like to understand like
why you believe what you believe but do
you not understand our point like the
people that are against it do you not
understand their point of view i think
their point of view is often it's my
body my choice right but i'm saying when
you take that to the extreme it doesn't
make sense have you had sex well i'm i'm
not a virgin so you've had sex what if
you had a baby
but but i was i was i no but here so so
so so here's the thing here's the thing
one if if i got pregnant i would keep it
because to me like i i don't believe in
abortion and i have um i have i have a
brother right and my mom got pregnant
when she was a teenager and she gave him
up for adoption and so to me it's like
do you think that's like that's a life
adoption usually kids that are in
adopted care it's not a good life in
that sense no he had a great life he's
he's married pregnant yes he had a great
life doesn't mean a lot of people go
into drugs
i just want you to like when you say
things like that it's it's the same
argument people use for eugenics do you
know what eugenic says so eugenics is
basically when you're when you're
getting a more pure population
and so a lot of times people would bring
things like low iq people need to be
exterminated like poor people need to be
exterminated and when you're using the
argument of if they have a bad life
that's how eugenicists use to make their
point because you're basically you're
implying that like poor people have less
of a right to life than rich people no
we're not we're not implying that i
think to do with it
if that baby is born when it could have
been aborted that could lead into a
worser life when it could have when that
could have been prevented
right so you don't think that's saying
that poor people should have a less of a
right to life than rich people it's not
about poor or rich like it's about
quality of life that has nothing to do
you could be poor and still have a good
quality of life like that has nothing to
do with it but like the baby like it's
quality of life like you don't know if
it's gonna be rich you don't know if
it's gonna impair you don't know where
it's gonna end up and you can't just you
can't you can't just give birth because
what if it's not a good life like some
people can't even look after themselves
yet and you're putting a baby with them
okay this is the one thing that people
don't understand about street interviews
i am always excited to talk to you guys
if you see me on the street whatever i
am so down to talk but if i'm doing an
interview it hurts the quality of the
interview when you guys interrupt me
when i am talking to the first person so
if you want to come up that's fine but
you have to like wait your turn
respectfully love you guys but again so
so
so so hey we're doing an interview i'd
love to interview you guys next i'd love
to hear but so again only eight percent
of women below the poverty line so the
majority do you not think facts matter
well not in when this is other people
that that's becoming illegal now think
of all the things that are going to
happen in america
it's just going to it's going to be
terrible why is that your your thought
that everything like what's going to
happen
it was unlegalized in the first place
like because it wasn't happening it
wasn't unlegalized you might not know
how the us government works but it's not
illegal in the us it's not illegal
so so the way it works in the u.s is
it's state by state so you elect
officials to represent you in each state
and that way if if you're a pro-life
person you can move to a state that's
pro-life if you're pro-choice you can
move to a state that's pro-choice why
should you have to move to a state why
can't you just well that's how the u.s
government works is you you have
different laws in every state
right so again less than one percent of
abortion so but this is but so this is
this is my channel we talk about we
don't talk about exceptions we're
talking about the rule so you don't talk
about acceptance we're talking because
this is what people often will try to
make an argument using the exception
when we're talking about the rule i'm
i'm asking you to like respectfully
we're not we're not talking about that
exception but what's
because 99 of abortions are due are not
in the case of grapes so we're talking
about the 99 percent
i have nothing to ask
that's the argument i'm making for the
99 of abortions that are not great it is
a cop-out because they made poor
decisions
what do you think about with
you don't you think that grapes so great
youtube what do you think then i'm
asking what is your opinion on great and
yeah because i think you're again you're
trying to make an argument i think
you're trying to make an argument for
like the exception rather than the rule
and so this because because because it's
less than one percent of the case but
this is what because i'm not talking
about that i could see a potential
policy for exceptions but i'm talking
about the rule and the i would say okay
little things
don't even exist
they don't what what are they not
exactly like
it's a con it's a human concept
construct that you're this the rule and
the exception it's still part of it do
you not see what i'm saying
but i but this is this is what i'm
talking about 90 the nine this is the
argument i'm making i i know but this is
this is you can do that on your channel
on my channel we're talking about the 99
of abortion that that are outside of
that case
you'll have you'll have like
most people here are going to talk about
that one percent yeah and i don't think
it's a good argument that's that's the
thing you can't even argue about it so
it clearly is a good argument because
you're done for you don't know what to
say because i i have an opinion on it
but we're not talking i wouldn't say i
wouldn't i would i wouldn't i wouldn't
say it i wouldn't say it
okay i i can do what i want on my
channel is the entire like in life i
forget about the channel what what okay
but i'm here this is a job so again like
you're coming to my job and saying this
is you need to talk about what i want on
your channel
no it's just
okay would you okay so would you agree
that the 99 percent of cases it's a cop
out outside of not at all
this isn't i don't think you're going to
change many people's minds in the uk
coming here you're it's actually
offending many people okay that's that's
okay you know it is
look at how many people have walked past
that's why we came over here
i was like what is on her like what are
you doing sorry no offense to you like
you're allowed to have your own choice
but we were in shock that's why we came
over because it's ridiculous i don't
it's crazy that you're kind of
brainwashed almost like that's our
opinion are we women you know america is
brainwashed they are crazy
yeah honestly like women can have an
opinion that doesn't agree with your
opinion
but no i'm saying i don't think you're
brainwashed because you have your
opinion so it's a little bit offensive
when you say that i'm brainwashed
because i disagree with you because
i don't i don't think you're brainwashed
i think you just have your opponent i
think in the respect that you're saying
ignore that i think that's why i think
that ignore that exception that's what
that's made us think the argument i'm
making isn't in the cases of great
that's not the argument i'm saying in 99
percent of cases it is a cop-out
blessing
for offending dude
it's okay it's okay and this is the
thing i'm not offended i think a lot of
girls are afraid they're going to hurt
my feelings ladies i do this every day i
am not offended the point is just to
show you that you have a flaw in logic
and it's very frustrating to me when if
i say i am pro life they try to degrade
everything that i said before it doesn't
matter to the to them
it doesn't matter to them if the facts
the data the statistics are all on my
side it's still
oh well you're pro-life you're
brainwashed
okay what's your name um you can call me
mali okay i'm pearl
nice to meet you so my opinion is that
in ninety nine percent of cases abortion
is a cop-out so it's it's for a poor
decision it's interesting that you use a
percentage in an opinion in that
instance because percentages are usually
used for fact-based things and you're
using using it for an opinion so it's
difficult to kind of respond to that so
if you think that 99 of abortions are
because it's not what what do you say
again because often times people bring
up the exception when i'm talking about
the rule
right so so i'm saying in 99 of cases
it's it's a cop-out for poor
reproductive choices i feel like
where for me it's like this if you're
going to say 99 that means you have to
have literally either a sample group of
like literally 99 people one person or a
ratio that's equal to that and it has to
come from a valued source so unless it's
your opinion which means it's false no
it comes from data that's it comes from
data like what so so in the usa like
trump posts like no no not
not trump post so no do you want to let
me talk i can tell you what's wrong so i
got it from the government website of um
of the uk and the us they survey
abortion clinics so people people are
are surveyed as to why they get an
abortion your sample group was the uk or
the us both and it's similar so you
sample group the uk and what states in
the u.s so one of them was florida off
the top of my head i can't tell you
every single one calculation that you
made is 99
of abortion sorry because
so again so again so so here's the thing
like i that's not the point the point
the point is that when when a woman
chooses to get an abortion outside of
grape i think it is a cop-out so and i
really would rather not go back and
forth about about great that's
completely fine i think everyone's
entitled to their opinion but the law is
completely different what is your
opinion my opinion
about what abortion yes my opinion of
abortion is i've never i've never gone
through it personally myself i'm not a
woman in that instance so i never know
exactly what it's like but if i was
going to have a child that i felt like i
couldn't care for then it would be
something i would consider in that
instance if i was in that situation so i
think it's especially when america
promotes the american dream which is
meant to be freedom it's ironic that
they're taking away choice what does
that have to do with anything i just
said you don't think when we have 10
different forms of birth control so we
can get it use a condom like that's what
i'm saying i'm saying we have choice
though as women you're saying like
you're acting like women don't have
choice and i'm saying i am a woman i'm
from the us and i i have the choice i
have i i i i i okay okay chinese
government was that kind of moving okay
so so i need you to let me finish again
we have i can use a condom i can do
abstinence i can get the iud i think you
guys call it the coil here i can get
birth control i can get a bunch of
different pills i can get that thing you
stick in your arm i can do adoption if i
want i think those are all val i can
also track when i'm ovulating i think
those are all valid choices i think
what's ironic about all those things
that you mentioned is they have a lesser
percentage of stopping a pregnancy than
your percentage that you have of
it's not 99 it comes to a condom it's
not 99 it's 99 it's 99.5 percent when it
comes to the coil an iud okay so that's
ironic because i said the condom and you
didn't mention that at all a condom so i
kind of mentioned a condom so a condom's
98 so if you do the coil and you have a
condom
you can do both it still stands if you
know what i'm saying no because because
that's not that's not that's not i said
that the things that you you okay that's
not accurate because again i also said
abstinence
that's 100 you mentioned that condoms
are 98 so if 98 chance that someone's
going to be pregnant
no no no it's not if if there's 98
chance uh no if there's a two percent
chance that someone could be pregnant
with using the condom but that's not an
effective form of contraception if i
can't have an abortion based off the
fact that 99 of abortion 99 of child
pregnancies that i want to
so yeah what's what's what about
abstinence abstinence what
not having sex what percent what percent
of pregnancies does that prevent i mean
abstinence is not really part of the
question that's like a random variable
that's like it is because i listed that
as a form of birth control you this
abstinence is a form of birth control
yeah what is abstinence to you bro what
are you talking about man not having sex
what personally anyone can yeah so
you're going to say
if you're going to promote abstinence
that's a choice
okay let me just think of a perfect
metaphor so another another stat that
people don't realize is 40 of women that
get abortions have had two or more both
in the uk you can look that up that's on
a uk government website and in the u.s
and they don't and so and they track
they track they track and they they
don't track the percent if they're going
to have abortions in the future that's
great so what do you think so is it
abstinence do you think that's a natural
thing do i think it's a natural thing no
i think i think abstinence very hard you
think it's an unnatural thing so what's
ironic about that is you promote that as
a solution
one of one of no no no no no
no no this is my channel this is my
channel this guy frustrated me because
i hate it when interviewees come up to
me and tell me how to interview them and
try to tell me what we're gonna talk
about no
this is my channel
i get to pick what we're talking about
not you
so yeah i had to i had to let him go
cause he wasn't listening he wasn't
listening this is this is this is my
channel this is my channel you're coming
to my job okay so i'm saying again i
that was one of many options that i
could like i mentioned but you
disregarded so you said you stuck on
abstinence so is this the state of
abstinence i i i i mentioned eight
different forms but you refused but you
refused initially hit me out when i said
condoms so they stick with abstinence
because you push abstinence we have
video evidence i'm saying so they stick
to abstinence so you said it's not a
natural thing you know what i'm saying
but the whole thing about this whole
abortion thing is how it's unnatural i
think i think abortions are unnatural
and that's your kind of argument for it
but when you're promoting the solution
to being unnatural things it's
hypocritical no no no no i i promoted
eight i promoted eight forms of
contraceptives
of eight that's two things that's two of
eight that i find hypocritical because
condoms are 98
again you're talking about so so this is
this is this is the problem is you're
looking for exceptions we're talking
about the rule so
that's that's you're talking about
exceptions and we're talking about the
rules so you have a 98 you even with
condoms you have a 98 chance of not
getting pregnant that's pretty good odds
so i'm saying that if you don't want to
use condoms you also have you also have
abstinence you can also get an iud you
can use a coil you can use birth control
you can do the thing
that is if my primary goal is to not get
pregnant what my primary goal is to have
sex and not have a pregnancy you take
you're removing you're removing very no
so then so so then you should use the
eight forms of contraception that we
have i should constantly use the eight
forms of contraception if i plan to have
sex even though one of those forms of
contraception is to not have sex you're
hypocritical it's interesting
how
liberals always bring up the exception
always always always always it's never
the this is a new term that someone in
the comment section said and i thought
it was so true they said the exception
does not disprove the rule and it's true
it's true what do you understand what
i'm saying that's a contradiction if
you're going to say that abstinence no
i'm saying abstinence is one i'm saying
abstinence is one one of the eights yes
which is one of the eight things that
i'm going to like you recommended to me
to control my content as contraception
no i'm i'm saying
i'm saying it's one of many so if you
don't want to do abstinence you can get
the coil which is 99.5 effective the
point is like you don't want to do the
coil you can get you can do birth
control if you don't want to get the
birth control you can you can get an eye
you can get some that thing that they
stick into your arm i forgot the name if
you don't want to do that there's
adoption like there is always a fail
safe and the issue that i have is you're
taking accountability off of women when
it's they're making a poor decision
hoffenhoff like again like like like
they'd be like you're arguing with me
over one percent 99 versus yeah because
you are because you keep is for the
whole 100 not the 99 the laws for 100 of
the people on this planet so you
you make laws based on the rules and not
the exceptions
and who said that
why would you do do you think that you
should make laws based on the exception
um if you if you're gonna try and make
me say some things that are not true but
i never mentioned asking you actually
relevant to this conversation because
you did you talking about rules come
from what was that like i said
laws are based on the rule they're not
based on the exception whose words are
those yours
i would i would say that the laws are
based off of the rule not the acceptance
speaking because so so
so
this is what we're here to talk about
opinions
so
the reason why it got difficult is
because you use percentages in opinions
okay so so again you're arguing with me
over two percent no because and so
that's like like when it comes to law
like it's for the hundred percent so you
can't literally just i think we make
laws based on the rule not the exception
you're arguing for 98 i'm arguing for
100 you understand you're saying this
two percent that's your perception
so so again again you're not even
debating me on what we're trying to talk
about so so okay okay so so because of
that i'm gonna go on to the next person
but thank you for stopping i appreciate
it
have a great one okay thank you
in the majority of cases abortion is a
cop-out and the reason i think this is
because 40 of women that get an abortion
have had two or more they're not they're
not tracking which women are going to
get abortions in the future so arguably
that number could be higher right and we
have so many different forms of birth
control right we have condoms we have
iuds we have that thing that they put in
your arm that are 99.5 effective 98 this
guy wanted to argue 98 that's still
that's still pretty effective right so
we have all these ways that we can
prevent pregnancies and if you still get
pregnant it's a cop-out for your poor
decision
i mean i don't completely disagree but i
don't know if i completely agree either
okay a lot of people argue that okay so
what about people who are financially
unable to look after the child or they
you know are raped or things of this
nature i know that's a that's a minority
so this is one misconception is that
poor people get abortions at higher
rates than richer people so actually
only eight percent of women below the
poverty line are getting abortions where
one out of three women that make forty
seven thousand dollars per year or more
are getting an abortion so it's the
majority of the women that are that are
getting these abortions can't afford it
right okay and so to me it's like
if you make 47k where a year you can you
can afford condoms right so it's really
it seems like the majority are just it's
a fail-safe for a poor reproductive
choice that you made
why do you think
abortion is pushed so much why do you
think it's something that is like really
heavily pushed by the media by certain
influences and we see it so much
nowadays especially as a younger
generation honestly i think so this is
something a lot of people don't know
about do you know where planned
parenthood's roots in the us yeah i do
racism yeah and so i think there's a
group of elites honest this is this is a
conspiracy don't i know the comments are
going to be like you do know
this is this is this part is conspiracy
but i think there's a group of elites
that believe in population control and i
think that's why they're doing it and
that's why 80 percent of planned
parenthood's in the us are in minority
communities the black population in the
us would be double today
yeah she referred to black people as
weeds and so it's like if nike was
founded by a racist people would be on
the streets why is this okay especially
when margaret sanger's grandson they
talk about how they want to market it to
minority women and they talk about how
they want to they make it a woman of
color issue and like that's that's how
they market it to minority in that her
project is called the n-word project her
grandson is still doing it he's in new
york he was the head of planned
parenthood in all of new york and he was
interviewed about roe versus wade and he
uses the same language like this affects
women of color when anyone can get an
abortion it's not it's not specifically
i think that's something a lot of people
should know about the roots of planned
parenthood especially when it ties to
race and
minority populations in america
um a lot of people will say that
removing
the choice to get an abortion is an
infringement on women's rights
and that it's going to keep kind of
coming after women's rights and that
kind of thing so it kind of brings in a
feminist movement with are they going to
go after women's votes are they going to
look after women being able to do this
and do that so what do you think about
that in terms of a women's rights
perspective what about the child's
rights it's like i think the child's
rights at conception there's a unique
dna sequence that's different from the
mother and the fathers right that dna
sequence has the eye color hair color
personality traits um and in china you
see you see something where they're
aborting women that's because of the one
child policy so what what about those
women so
and that's that's the problem with
abortion is it becomes a slippery slope
to eugenics where a lot of the arguments
i hear people make are something along
the lines of poor people should
shouldn't live and shouldn't be alive
when everyone on earth is richer than
most people were in all of human history
you know by that logic no one should be
i think a lot of people also get caught
up with the whole
point of life discussion so a lot of
people who are kind of pro life will say
that as soon as um the sperm and the egg
kind of come together that is somewhat a
form of life starting but it seems to be
this kind of um as you said like
slippery stuff as to where life starts
and i think if i don't think i
personally don't demonize those who are
pro-life or pro-choice because i think
they both come from a point of like i
see where they're coming from both sides
i feel like one side gets heavily
demonized and the conversation just gets
completely skewed
that's why i didn't want to answer you
over there because as soon as i say
pro-life nobody wants to hear anything
yeah which which isn't it's not really
fair because another thing is a lot of
people i think if they saw what
abortions looked like they wouldn't they
wouldn't be cool with it they pull off
the limbs one by one they crush the head
and they vacuum it out for surgical
abortions yeah and and if they did that
to puppies people would be an uproar
yeah yeah it's weird because when it's a
human
yeah and i again this isn't something
and they also a lot of people say oh you
know as men
yeah we shouldn't have an opinion on
this kind of stuff yeah something
interesting that you as a woman who you
know seems to kind of have a a fork in
the discussion
is giving your opinion because if i was
here with this no one would bother
listening to me as a woman i think it's
important that women have this
discussion amongst themselves
and try to like have a dialogue that
kind of looks at both sides of the
spectrum
but i think the last two weeks the whole
roe v wade thing yeah it was you
couldn't escape it like i wasn't exactly
sure where i was with it because again
i'm not gonna say i'm pro-life or
pro-choice i think there are some ex
some situations where i don't blame a
woman for getting an abortion again if
she's under age and she's in that kind
of i get that but um you know when it is
used as a form of contraception as you
said that most people get two or more
the activity just seems like it's a sort
of contraception and that is something
that a difficult people know about if
they if they knew that abortion was used
as a form of contraception maybe the
discussion would be a bit different i
think do you know what her program is
i've heard the term i can't tell exactly
pergame is basically like women date
across and up hierarchies and so a girl
wants to know when she has a kid that's
the best i can do so that's why you see
a lot of girls chasing after rich guys
trying to get their kids right and to me
abortion is the ultimate form of
hypergamy because she's saying this
isn't the best i could do because if a
girl is really into you she is not
aborting that kid you couldn't pay her
to okay
that's interesting i mean i can't no
one's no one no one's supporting steph
curry's kid no one's important
that's that's an interesting part of the
conversation how finance how economics
how social status plays a part into it i
get that that makes a lot of sense a lot
of people say things like oh especially
me as a man you know you're not carrying
the child
you know you can't say what whatever
whatever i think you may have a point in
there as well i mean again i would love
to say devil's advocate to what you're
saying but everything you're kind of
saying the things i fought myself
but i don't say publicly per se
because
until now but again
when i found out the roots of
planned parenthood margaret sanger
eugenics reducing the black population
that's something i i can't ignore yeah
right so a lot of black people should
know this kind of stuff a lot of
minority people should know this stuff
about where the whole push for um
abortion came from especially our
communities you know it's not something
that we should just really nearly go
along with do your research find things
out for yourself don't just go along
with what the media and everything
everyone's telling you because history
will say something different and that's
the crazy thing is i i don't understand
why people don't freak out about this
information like and it's the same
people running the organizations like
it's not like it's a new new people and
a lot of times the arguments you hear
about abortion are honestly a form of
eugenics which which indicate that
people of lower iq should be
exterminated people that are poor should
be exterminated i don't think people
know that's what they're arguing but
when they when they start to bring out
well she can't afford those kids well
most people are richer today than they
ever could have been in human history
poor people have air well not in the uk
y'all don't have air conditioning here
but but poor people have smartphones
nobody in history could have had that
right okay so in terms of the whole kind
of um discussion around abortion in that
so i'm guessing you're american yeah i
am do you think there's a difference
between how americans view the
conversation around how british people
view the conversation people are more
left like people are a lot more
pro-choice here in my experience like
people are more like angry more angry
yeah about it like when i bring this
sound out i'm like more scared here
i'm not i mean it's fine but like it's
just i i find that like there's more
people that agree with me in the u.s
interesting interesting it depends where
you are though if i went to la that
would probably be a different absolutely
absolutely i mean again i think the
whole kind of thing with
pro-choice and pro-life is a bit again
even to me that's a bit skewed because
pro-choice is okay everyone should have
a choice in life i suppose everyone
should have a choice to do whatever they
want right but and then you got pro-life
is basically saying i want these
children to live and i don't know i feel
like it's not exactly fair because if
you're pro-life it's like oh you're the
most extreme person ever we cancel you
put you out of any sort of like civil
discourse but then if you're pro-choice
you can be pro-choice but for the most
part still want to tell to live on most
occasions so you can actually be
pro-choice but more in common with
someone who's pro-life than someone
who's really like oh pro-abortion yeah
get it get it get it all the time so
i feel like even that is still a bit
skewed i don't think it's a it's a fair
point to kind of you know you know it's
a crazy stat too do you know when
abortion's legal here what when or why
like how long how long uh it's not been
that long i believe in northern ireland
it's still not no no i meant like how
long like how far along i can get an
abortion in a pregnancy
i actually really enjoyed talking to
these two people because
they were just very open to like
listening and learning and
i really enjoy conversations where i
feel like i'm learning from them they're
learning from me we're both open to
different ideas and it's not just a
heated debate or you know i believe what
i believe regardless of any facts data
or statistics
yeah 20.
six months oh so no do you know the
earliest child that survived birth like
survived
like four five months or something like
that yeah 21 weeks and it's legal up to
24. yeah see
some of these kids like could
hypothetically yeah it could be real
living people breathing people so that
to me again i can't after you saying
that i can't pretend like that sits
right with me yeah it doesn't and i
don't think a lot of people knowing five
months along six months along then you
terminate the pregnancy only in
situations where the mum the mother
could die yeah most pro-lifers would
agree with that when it's the life of
the mother most pro-lifers would agree
i can understand that but if there's not
a true health risk going on i would
really struggle to find peace with
somebody doing that i really would so
sometimes
i can see people walking by and i can
tell they have an opinion and i can tell
they want to talk to me
but a lot of people are too afraid to
stand on what the what they believe
and really have a conversation in the
open about it i get it not everyone
wants to be filmed but
i i think societies run better when we
can all have open and honest
conversations and sometimes i'll be
wrong sometimes i'll take l sometimes
they'll take l's it's just part of the
game but if you're not open to having
those conversations it's like where do
we get in a society and you're not
owning up to the consequences of it
i don't know what to say
i don't know what to say um i just think
men don't have no rights putting their
opinion towards it that's that's why i
can say towards it men have no right
yeah
when it comes to abortion they shouldn't
have a say
why do you think that ends because it's
a woman's body so i have a woman that's
going to push it out
not them that's going to go through it i
have a question do you think since it's
a woman's body do you feel like we
should be able to have abortions a month
before we give bor give birth
a month before it shouldn't even reach a
month i know what i'm saying if it's my
body shouldn't it like wouldn't you say
based on that logic it's my body mind be
a month if you wanted never wanted it
then you should have been careful with
you know i i agree but i but don't you
think they should have been careful
before it was born like because a lot of
girls will have sex with guys that
shouldn't be fathers and instead of
being more selective with who we sleep
with and maybe being on birth control we
make poor decisions and then this is
just like a way to be bailed out
basically yeah that's true that is true
and so do you think that's a problem you
don't think that's a problem some men
don't deserve to be fathers at all
some men don't deserve to be fathers
though
we shouldn't be sleeping with them right
yeah that's true did you know that 40 of
women that get abortions they've had two
or more
so it's like we're we keep seeing women
it's like we're just not being careful
clearly not three percent is almost 50.
what 30 is almost 50. yeah and i mean 60
it's their first one we don't know how
many they'll have in the future just
becoming like a cop-out as opposed to
being responsible with our body i really
i think babies are live so if you never
wanted it don't like just take it away
life is life you know so you're pro-life
yeah i'm confused i'm confused right now
g okay i didn't i misunderstood you when
you said my body might change no no i'm
pro-life yeah what made you prolong the
simple fact that not everyone can have
babies
and like everyone always want that
opportunity people have like
miscarriages and like try and try
and yeah what do you what do you think
to the people that say that like it's
too much of an overreach like it's our
body you shouldn't have done it then
this is impossible they oh my god thank
you that's like i've never find girls
that agree with me this is okay okay
do you have any social media you want to
play um yeah six more six i-x-m-u-l-l-a
thank you so much have a good one
so today we're talking about that we i
think abortion is a cop-out you mean
like it's just like uh it's like oh i
forgot now i can just get an abortion i
think i think most women make poor
decisions
and they're not being careful and what
was supposed to be a last resort is now
becoming a cop out for poor decisions
but there's so but it's so broad there's
so many different types of abortions
okay so like what are you defining as an
abortion do you do is plan b an abortion
yes or no what what say you okay so i
don't i don't have an opinion on plan b
because i honestly don't know enough
about plan b
so i'm so broad i'm talking about the
data that i'm talking about was taken
from abortion centers so it's not it's
not including plan b i'm saying i'm
saying it's not like it's such a broad
here all i know i was telling your
friend over here is that i'm a father of
two daughters
and you know you know what you know what
my opinion should be
my opinion should be shut the [ __ ] up
brandon
but i can have a voice because i'm a
girl right of course sir what
i don't even i'm saying for me my dog
like i'm if i sit around the dinner
table i'm not allowed i shouldn't have
an opinion
really i think men should have an
opinion it's their kid this is why we
have a lack of masculinity in society
guys stop letting women tell you that
you can't have an opinion because you're
a man if anything we should listen to
men we should listen to men we're
emotional we get on our period once a
month we're crazy we are nuts and men
don't have that so if you don't go to
men for logic what what do we have in a
society and we our society is so
brainwashed that we have convinced men
that they can't have an opinion
on
a child that is half theirs that they
helped make
you don't think okay you don't think
your daughters you you would rather
teach them to be careful with who they
sleep with well no but you know what i
am doing i'm i'm not i'm not hiding
meaning that i don't we're open at every
we're open like were your parents open
with you at the table like were you
afraid were you able to say anything
will you be able to ask them anything
and would they honestly give you the
answers yeah
well that's good because that's how
that's our approach our approach is like
you know what this is this is what an
iud is this is you know where you know
have your guy wear a condom go on the
pill because you know what there's some
parents that don't talk about the pill
okay and they're like god forbid i don't
want to talk about the pill because you
know i don't think my kid is
sexually active when in reality they
could be teen pregnancies are actually
dropping and the majority of abortions
are actually over the age of 21. so i
just think if you're getting an abortion
if you're getting an abortion over the
age of 21 you you know the reproductive
you you know and i think
it's like too old i respect your opinion
i respect his opinion and his opinion i
respect everybody's opinion
so that's that's what mine so but i'm
not judging anybody so if you believe
that but everybody should be able to
choose what they want to do
okay so today we're talking about
abortion yeah so my my statement is that
in the majority of casein cases abortion
is a cop-out okay i'm from new york what
do you mean about a cop house like what
does that what does that mean
so basically it it means that you made a
poor choice and you don't want to deal
with the consequences okay i disagree i
think that having and deciding to have
an abortion is actually a choice of
power and courage and you're
acting over your body and your decision
and being a parent deciding to be a
parent and to be a mother is such a
great deal than forcing a kid to grow up
when you don't have the economical or
mental issues and reasons to like birth
and like carry a child i think it like
it doesn't make any sense so the
misconception is that people that are
poorer are more likely to get abortions
only eight percent of women below the
poverty line are getting abortions where
women that make forty seven thousand
dollars per year or more one out of
three get abortion so it's not really an
economic issue yeah but it doesn't have
to do with economic it has to do with
your mental health if you don't want to
have a child then you shouldn't bring a
child into the world but don't you think
they should be more careful when they're
having sex then
like yeah but accidents happen and that
doesn't mean that you have to like have
a child because i think it's worse for
you to have it than to have an abortion
because it doesn't make any sense so the
problem is 40 of women that have
abortions they've had two or more
already so it's not necessarily like the
majority of women and they don't track
out of the 60 who get them in the future
no no i don't think like i don't think
that's accurate and like also from
planned parenthood and looking about
like person like yeah that might be
accurate but at the same time it's a
personal decision so like every woman
has to make a choice over their body
because it's their body and it has
nothing to do with like whether society
says it has to do or whether it happens
or not happens and the fact that
abortion is now being like real versus
weight is being overruled in new york is
such a sad thing that happened and it
makes you think like oh my god if this
is happening then what happens to my
rights then what happens to me
i have the right to be abstinent yeah i
think you have you have the right to not
go through an abortion and carry for the
pregnancy at the same time another woman
has a right to not carry and go on with
him okay so here's here's my question do
you think abortion should be legal up to
birth
um you said my body my choice so when i
think of my body my choice like even
though the week before i give birth it's
still my body my choice and this is the
question they can't answer if it's my
body my choice then stand on that logic
abortion should be legal up to birth
stand on it or don't have the argument
at all